italy's lockdown keeps getting tightened
and you feel it the roads emptying of
cars and filling with checkpoints please
in rome and now even limiting how often
people buy groceries maravilla the
finest piece of usually fines have now
grown to three thousand euros for anyone
found moving around without the correct
documents and an essential reason for
being outdoors explain what's happening
here and this will be a go so this
checkpoint here is stopping people
passing every car thing off for their
document to explain their reason for
being out of the house and the italian
government the authorities here say it's
only a strict lockdown like this that
will help relieve the crisis here and
the sooner a country can take action
like this the better walter HRD is the
scientist who told the italian
government to call lockdown he says the
only thing that shocked him about this
pandemic is the reaction of politicians
example of italy UK could have adopted
but surely mr. Ricciardi compares images
he's seen of packed trains on the london
underground with a football match in
milan last month which accelerated the
contagion in northern italy 40,000 fans
travelling from Bergamo
now the epicentre of this pandemic what
point do you think the UK Boris Johnson
should have implemented lockdown I would
say at least 10 days ago what difference
will that have make that it didn't
happen 10 days ago the cases that they
have been generated 10 days ago wouldn't
have taken place you pay a price in in
sick people and in deaths and certainly
this is about something that could be
avoided and could it result in a longer
lockdown yeah I think at least one month
but I guess that could be even longer
the scientist who called Europe's first
lockdown is now advised
the Italian government to adopt similar
mobile phone tracking to South Korea he
says normality as we know it won't fully
resume until a vaccine is found and it
could be summer before we travel again
within Europe sunny Lockwood sky names